well so so the way the do i understand
girdle doing it is that he you know he
comes up with this whole girdle
numbering
approach
and he he takes you through and and
shows you this this mapping from the
from the numbers into these girdle
numbers that are making statements about
the numbers themselves
and you look at that and you go yeah
okay bye i understand that mapping
that's perfectly fine
and now i can write down within that
mapping i can write down this number
and when i look at the interpretation of
that number under this mapping
the the number says
i am true but not provable within piano
and so so now um
i mean at this point i sort of agree
with roger penrose
penrose looks at that and says okay that
that means that there is something true
here
um i can see that it's true it's i i
don't disbelieve i mean i saw the whole
girdle numbering construction
i saw how the sentence came to say what
it says and i agree that it's that that
it's all consistent
and what it's saying
is saying that it's true and not
provable
so so so at this point
i
i guess i sort of agree with penrose at
that point i go okay there's something
beyond the notion of
proof
beyond the notion of derivation that's
going on here there's the looking at
analogies
um and understanding analogies
that where we go this this sentence is
clearly true and it's also by its own
statement its own declaration
that it's not provable within
within this this finite computational
system yeah
perros is fascinating he thinks that our
brains are physical systems and he also
thinks that our mental processes are
generated by the brain probably
but uh that our brains can do
mathematics that go beyond the
mathematics that computers can do that
is a very specific statement that is
more concrete i think specific than what
you've said so far sure sure and it
leads him to uh to a weird spot which is
quite lonely at the moment but i find
this nevertheless a very interesting
argument to make i'm afraid we will not
be able to resolve it today because i
have to drop now yeah but
i found it very interesting to see that
you are appendrosis at the end of the
day
well um i don't like the microtubules
theory you know i don't like the the
non-complicated classification i think
he's not really to be blamed for this i
suspect that his reasoning is that since
all neuron physics is computational
these basically takes a state and then
there is a transition between the states
the uh resolution for what consciousness
where it comes from uh if consciousness
is enabling us to do things that
computers cannot needs to be in an
unknown area of physics and the unknown
area of physics that's left
reasoning in the same way as sherlock
holmes if you actually exclude all the
possibilities uh the only remaining
thing must be the truth right that's
quantum gravity because there is no
generally accepted theory of quantum
gravity right right and then it just so
happens that uh hammeroff has this
beautiful psychedelic uh theory of uh
how to get the microtubules to have
non-local interactions that employ
quantum gravities in a way that nobody
really understands right and this might
be in this corner and so
they they become friends
but i don't think that penrose theory is
exactly the same thing as hammeroff's
theory right right
right and i'm not talking about that
more general theory of consciousness i'm
just talking about his specific analysis
of girdle's incompleteness theorem and
what it means for mathematics yes
and it's basically also something that
chomsky is a few into in which leads
chomsky to mysterianism so basically
they are confronted with the same
insight or the same idea that they think
that human brains can do things that
mathematics cannot
that mathematicians can make proofs that
computers in principle cannot make that
they discover that certain statements
are true that in a computable exomatic
system cannot be derived and this was
also what my question was pointing up at
how do you know that something is true
there if you cannot go show me a
sequence of steps
that that does it right and so uh
penrose and uh
thinks
that there must be unknown physics
and um swamskis thinks it cannot be
understood in principle which might be
the same thing at the end of the day
right i i guess we will have to go i'll
just say
our basic understanding of the axioms
itself
then maybe one thing to
how do i understand the basic axioms
that are the foundation of the
computational system where does that
understanding come from is that from
within the computational system or does
that ex does that escape the
computational system
from my own perspective it's
the case that my mind is constructing a
model of reality where the reality that
i found myself to be in is something
like a physics engine in which my own
conscious serve
acts as a puppet as a simulacrum that is
being used to tell the story about an
intelligent agent and i don't see any
limitations in my ability to make models
that could produce such an agent that
would find itself in this world and
associate a set of
valence precepts with
a garlic and another one
with sunlight and
that happens entirely through the
relational nature of my unified model of
the universe that is being derived by
completely non nefarious computation
that are approximated in nervous systems
right so i don't see where i currently
stand uh that this doesn't work out
and i uh
very sympathetic to when you don't see
this
that it doesn't work out and that you
have to
think that you have to find the truth
elsewhere and it could be that i am
going to change my mind in the future
when i stumble on something that
basically shows to me that
that what i'm intellectually trying
doesn't work so far it seems to work and
i appreciate that we have this
difference in our perspectives because
it's a very productive and useful one to
have